une rigueur budgétaire qui est
absolument indispensable il faut
réaliser que le défi budgétaire du
québec qu'il est majeur 7 milliards de
dollars d'impasse à rattraper c'est pas
banal c'est pas arrivé souvent au québec
mais l'alternative c'est quoi
l'alternative c'est de nous laisser en
déficit chronique continuer à augmenter
notre endettement ça ça va plomber les
femmes et ça ça va plomber l'économie
est hors de question qu'on laisse le
québec dans cet état là pour le prochain
les prochaines années surtout pas pour
la prochaine génération des jeunes qui
vont diriger le québec dans quelques
années doivent retrouver la liberté de
leur choix la liberté d'action et nous
on veut baisser le fardeau fiscal des
familles douala au terme du mandat grâce
et liquides et budgétaire pourquoi
l'urgence parce qu'on peut plus se
permettre de repousser à plus tard ce
qui aurait dû être fait c'est bien sûr
qu'on aimerait parfois balayé les choses
sur le tapis ou prétendent que les
choses ne sont pas aussi aux gens tout
aussi nécessaire et remettre à plus tard
on en a plus les moyens
après si ce déficit consécutif avec une
dette publique qui atteint 55% du pib ce
qui dans le contexte nord-américain est
important et partiellement dans le
contexte canadien
on note simplement plus la place là pour
absorber des déficits supplémentaires
sur un ou deux ans de plus il faut
rétablir l'équité c'est absolument
essentiel